[Music]
[Applause]
perfect game is more skill or luck right
now it's 64 saying luck okay which is
really interesting well I asked David
Cohn that because he threw a perfect
game how much is luck and how much is
skill it feels like it's exactly
backwards it's got to be at least 70
skill and then some luck I would say
it's
well you know what I'm not going to give
my number yet I'm going to bring in
David Cohn ask him since he threw a
perfect game David thanks for joining us
if we were going to go the percentage of
skill and luck and throw throwing a
perfect game what would you say that
percentage would be
well it's an interesting point because
not every pitch thrown in in a perfect
game is a perfect pitch so when you do
make a mistake the hitters have to
cooperate right and miss it or pop it up
and certainly there were a few of those
last night for Domingo Herman but I will
say this there's much more stress in a
perfect game every time you get your
three ball count you know you can blow
it with a walk whereas you know if you
walk somebody in a no-hitter you still
have the no-hitter so we've seen no
hitters thrown with four five six seven
eight walks sometimes and but that's
different in a perfect game much more
pressure so I would say the skill is
more important in a perfect game because
of the pressure than a no-hitter where
you have margin for error if you walk a
guy I'm wondering more pressure is felt
by the pitcher in a perfect game or his
teammates in a perfect game
that that's a great question Dan I know
I watched David Wells throw his perfect
game the year before mine we went back
to back years 1998 1999 and I was a
wreck watching his perfect game in The
Dugout I mean I was a just a nervous
wreck uh the and when you're actually
participating when you're the pitcher in
a perfect game you were just desperate
to maintain your focus nobody wants to
talk to you you your anxiety ridden when
you're when you're the pitcher in that
game so maintaining your emotions is a
full-time job whereas actually watching
it well you you allow all those negative
thoughts to creep into your mind you
know what if he blows it what if
something happens you know you have more
time to think if you're actually
watching it
as a pitcher when you take the mound is
your goal to throw a perfect game every
time you take them out I mean you have
to have that mindset when you go out
there
well yeah I think your goal is to win
every pitch your goal is to not walk
anybody your goal is to consistently get
ahead in the count and maintain count
leverage so yeah in that sense I guess
you know you you certainly want to win
every at-bat you want to get everybody
out that you can and then when you do
give up hits you you know you kind of
brush it off because that's to be
expected but yeah your mentality is sort
of going in strike one I'm gonna get
this guy out I'm gonna get ahead of him
and then get them out and stay on top of
stay on top of the hitters all day long
what do you remember about your perfect
game it came against the Montreal Expos
uh who was in the lineup that day that
you worried about
well Vladimir Guerrero was in that
lineup a Hall of Famer Jose vidro a
really good player and All-Star second
baseman was in that lineup uh so those
guys those two really worried me more
than anything and Vladimir Guerrero
presented an interesting problem because
he could hit everything he was the best
bad ball hitter since Yogi Berra you
know yoga could hit everything over his
head you know almost one hop but we saw
Vladimir Guerrero get a hit when the
ball actually bounced one time so no
matter what you know which pitch I threw
I he was the guy I worried about because
he could hit anything
did you use stick him stuff or sticky
stuff back then
not a lot really occasionally on a cool
night I would grab the rosin bag that
was in the batter's box Circle because
it had a little pine tar on it so yeah I
mean I guess you could say yeah I did at
times use a little bit of pine tar with
rosin mixed on a cold night but we
didn't realize how much it could help
your spin rate we didn't know anything
about spin rates back then or if we did
we didn't know how to measure them so
certainly I was worried about blisters
too if you use too much stick them is
that going to rip the pads off my
fingers I was more worried about uh you
know worried about messing up my
fingertips and getting blisters than
anything else with sticky stuff I'm
wondering why baseball doesn't come out
with their own products that these are
the only products you can use and that's
it this this is going to be approved by
hitters this will be approved by
pitchers and anything after that you're
going to face a really long suspension
yeah I think Major League Baseball feels
like they kind of have done that with
just the rosin bags that are on the
mound itself and that's what they're
policing this year you can't have your
own resin bag in your locker you can
only use the one on the mound you can't
weaponize the rosin if it gets too
sticky we're gonna bang you for that too
the problem with Major League Baseball
is they're obsessed with strikeout rates
the strikeout rates are so high in the
game today that if they present a new
product or a sticky baseball like the
one they have in Japan a pre-treated
baseball that the pitchers are going to
take advantage of that and increase the
strikeout rates so I think that's why
Major League Baseball is reluctant to do
exactly what you said Dan and sort of
come up with a universal product that
works they're worried about pictures
weaponizing whatever they they introduce
into the game and increasing the
strikeout rates yeah I'm wondering about
that because there's no shame in
striking out anymore
you know it's not a big deal it used to
be it was like you know hitters would
hang their heads as they walk back to
the Dugout when did it change that it
it's not an embarrassment to strike out
150 times yeah it's sort of a perfect
storm of things uh you know I think the
underrated facet is the strike zone
itself back in the 90s and 80s it was
more of an East and West Strike Zone and
if you threw a pitch right down the
middle and the catcher caught it at his
mask that was an automatic ball much
less High curve balls that were up that
way that are called strikes nowadays so
it's more of a North and South Strike
Zone we don't get those pitches off the
edges like we used to I mean Greg Maddox
and John Smoltz and Tom glavin and
myself we all lived off the edge of
thigh high off the outside corner that
was where the margin was we got we got
pitches called off the plate strikes but
we never got the high strike called so
that's the difference the power pitchers
are throwing harder than ever before the
strike zone is higher than it's ever
been before really you have to go back
to Jim Palmer back with the outside
chest protectors remember the bubble
chest protectors yeah Lee wire those old
umpires that was the higher Strike Zone
back then in the 60s and 70s but
pitchers didn't throw as hard as they do
nowadays so every reliever throws 95
miles an hour plus a lot of them 100
miles an hour that coupled with a high
Strike Zone has led to a higher
strikeout rate along with hitters trying
to drive the ball the power is premium
power hitting power pitching equals more
strikeouts talking to David Cohn the uh
yes Yankee analyst joining us on the
program viewer Yankee you were a met uh
if you were a Met fan can you can you
say let's be patient if you know Steve
Cohen said hey I'm not going to act like
you want me to I'm not firing anybody
we're not doing anything crazy here how
do you preach patience with a team
that's got a payroll as large as the
men's
really hard to do right now they're you
know the Atlanta Braves are a juggernaut
running away with the east
now you're eight and a half gains out of
the final wild card spot if you're the
match right now so if you're looking at
the very final wild guard spot like the
Philadelphia Phillies did last year and
rode all the way to to the World Series
they won 86 games and still got to the
World Series that's a long shot for the
Mets right now they have according to uh
you know betting odds or predictive odds
that are out there like less than a five
percent chance right now just to make
the playoffs so that is in and of itself
daunting they really need to look at
this trade deadline as sort of
reconfiguring their roster in my opinion
sort of uh what pieces don't fit
together what pieces are kind of Aging
they have a some pretty good young
players that have come up and helped
whether it's Brett Beatty at third base
or Alvarez at the catching position they
have a couple of others that are on the
way as well that's the future for them
they sort of need to reconfigure their
roster they probably need to look for
trade Partners I wouldn't be surprised
to see even the Yankees and the Mets
hook up in this trade deadline because
Billy eppler used to work for Brian
Cashman Steve Cohen the owner of the
Mets doesn't care where the trades come
from he doesn't have this sort of
mentality this anti-yanky mentality he's
a businessman so the days of the willpon
zoning the Mets and not trading with the
Yankees are kind of over in my mind so
there could be a match there if the
Yankees need an outfielder do they match
up with somebody like a Starly Marte or
something like that you know I think
those are the type of the deals the type
of deals the Mets need to look for at
this trade deadline I'm wondering if 15
years from now we look back on
shoheiotani in what he kind of birthed
that you will have these two-way players
that you know in high school your
shortstop is your pitcher and usually
batting third in the lineup there and I
don't know if you were like that but it
feels like these guys grow up being
hitters and being pitchers are we going
to have not a wave but at least a few of
these two-way players in Major League
Baseball
it's a great question Dan I think yes I
think shohei Otani is inspirational in
that regard he's he's a Trailblazer he's
showing the way and there's certainly we
saw we saw kids in the College World
Series this year that are two-way
players that are throwing the ball in
the upper 90s you know the left-hander
uh for Florida that started that final
game is one of those kids uh as well so
yes my answer is yes we're gonna see
kids that try to do it organizations
that will bring them along in the minor
leagues and kind of experiment with it
and allow them to explore whether they
can handle both or not but why not you
know shohei Otani is the MVP because
he's he plays uh such an important role
on their team on both sides of the ball
so why wouldn't you want that why
wouldn't you want that double value if
you can develop that in your own system
should he get two salaries
interesting well you know what he should
get is probably equity in the team that
signs him you know at this point I mean
if you're trying to sign shohei Otani
and you're the you're the uh Anaheim
Angels you know how do you entice him
well what would you do with the trade
deadline if if they haven't agreed to
anything contract extension not much has
been made public here but at some point
the angels have to have something in
return if shohei doesn't want to stay
yes I I believe that they need him to
stay so badly that they need to hold on
to him and hope they get into the
playoffs and hope he becomes a a
postseason hero for them at least get
them in a position to win a wild card
spot in the west which they currently
are very much in the running for so yes
you let that play out because your best
chance to sign shohei Otani back is a
long and deep postseason run with him
and Mike Trout that kind of shows him
hey you should stay right here we're on
the right we're on the right move here
where we're moving in the right
direction so yeah with that being said
there might be a blockbuster trade out
there Dan you're right I mean you have
to listen you have to listen if there's
a blockbuster trade where you can really
get an incredible value back then you
have to consider it but I still believe
they want to keep him and the best way
to keep him is to get to postseason and
show him what it's like and to have
postseason ball at the big eight great
to talk to you as always David thanks
for joining us my pleasure Dan anytime
it's David Cohn five World Series champ
and he's an analyst for the Yankees Yes
Network he threw his perfect game at
Yankee Stadium against the Expos and
back in 1999